what up guys welcome to the just pearly
things youtube channel today i am going
to be reacting
to some fresh and fit podcast clips
before i start do not forget
to hit that subscribe button you guys
already know i'm trying to hit 20
000 subscribers that's a big goal for
the channel and do not forget to ring
the notification bell that way you're
going to be notified of my daily videos
okay so this clip just came up on my
newsfeed i thought it
looked interesting it's a proof that
girls put emotion
first over facts i consider myself a
very logical person
so this will be interesting to like see
what i think of this because i consider
myself like
a fact person
oh my gosh is it on sometimes i turn up
the speed on accident
oh my gosh all right there's a study
done uh back in like 2018.
from studies
which accounts for a large portion of
people explain it exactly
yeah so so go back okay i disagree with
this i'm like a big
study person i think studies there's
definitely something to said about
be said about studies but when people
tend
to question like different studies
i think what they're trying to say is
that
you never really know it's it's hard as
a regular person to understand the
difference between a valid study and an
invalid study because
anyone knows that you can find a study
that says anything
and so differentiating between like
valid studies and invalid studies is
hard
uh because even like people in the man
of spirit i'm sure that you guys would
agree there's like
some far left like feminist studies that
you would 100
disagree with for like a reason x y and
z
i would love to see a youtube video
about how to differentiate between like
quality studies and non-quality studies
that would be a good video i don't know
how to do it so that's what i'm saying
someone
make that the saturday night attitude
for me right
this is so embarrassing what's so
embarrassing i don't know you guys
making us look stupid
yeah no they're not making us no no baby
they're not making us look stupid at all
they might be they're just talking to us
like children yeah and that that's what
okay the people are not fresh and fit
definitely not the um
i don't know their names but not the
like the side guy but the guy who's like
the main guy in the show
he talks down to people and is very
arrogant
and like he kind of reminds me of like
your typical like male chauvinist
like if i had to cast someone i don't
know him personally
so if you see this sorry my opinion
doesn't matter where it's like a problem
like like these things the way they talk
to women like i think puts themselves
so like this will refute our argument
though
how can we feed your argument when we
don't have statistics
it's not about having statistics yes it
is everything you guys have said has
been like statistics show
no well here's the thing if you guys are
going to make an argument you should be
able to back up that argument correct
but how are we supposed to back up the
argument when you guys had homework
okay yeah i know what they're saying
they're saying like
we didn't we don't do this for a living
but ladies you knew you're coming on the
show
come on you guys have time to do this
it's just about just about like
understanding the world and like
you said that right exactly so you're
proving my point you can't be mad at us
for being
intelligent enough to be able to
substantiate our points that we give you
because
but the one thing i will say is that if
you view the world through a certain
lens you're only going to see it through
that lens so one thing i've noticed in
the manosphere
is they'll always say like a girl like
settled for a beta something like that
but what irritates me about that is then
you're gonna say like any 25
to like 30 year old that gets married
right that her
like the person she ends up marrying
ends up always being a beta what are you
talking about
like you can't have previous
relationships that that was a little off
topic
as you guys know these no these are very
unfiltered and unedited but that's just
what
i think of when i think of like what
these girls are saying they're saying
when you view the world through a
certain lens like that's all you're
going to see
you guys say before i remember oh you
said uh
like these girls don't even know what
they want that's like something that you
say like a little kid doesn't know what
he wants
so i bring him into a canvasser and you
tell me what she's literally about to
tell you it's statistically proven that
women do not know what they're sexually
aroused by that's fine
oh sexually arousal i can tell you i
want to be slapped in the [ __ ] face
okay that's cool
that's right that's one thing but the
point the the argument was this
let's let's make this because those are
why we gotta go clarify
do you guys have parents we're not
talking about gosh
well they're both intertwined so what
i'm saying is that women are not
they do not know what they're attracted
to and you should not listen to female
dating advice
okay was made by a man and then i was
actually done at an independent study in
northwestern university
so um so they did a study and i was
about to tell it and then you're like
triggered
well you treat those like children it's
not that i'm treating you like children
it's just that
i'm i'd like to hear this i made a claim
and now i'm substantiating it with
statistics i'm open to listening oh my
gosh but it's the way he talks to them
like he gets
so like
i don't like the way he talks thanks for
me i obviously have noticed i do i am
careful with how i speak
um i don't expect that from anybody else
and i'm definitely not she's
beautiful she looks like scarlett
johansson i'm triggered but i will i
will say what bothers me if something
bothers me well okay
well that's fine if it bothers you but
facts are facts
legs are feelings that's fine and i'm
i'm looking forward to hearing
uh what you have to say and question um
i just teach kids and kids get very
triggered and emotional and talks over
adults so
um can i ask uh do you guys think that
this is
emotional and triggered behavior the way
that i'm acting right now when you cut
them off many many many times
it is yeah just listen i mean i was
gonna i was gonna back my claims up
that's i'm not gonna make a crazy
okay but the one who is cutting them off
was this girl right here
i'm pretty sure she seems pretty
level-headed this girl's quiet
you know claim women don't know what
they want without substantiating it
so i'm listening i i said a few times
i'm listening so what they did was
long story short i'm going to give you
guys the cliff notes because it was a
very long and complex study what they
did was they took men women and
homosexual men they showed them erotic
images and they gave them
uh they put electrodes on their genitals
and they gave them a finger pointer okay
to click on the thing
yeah so what they did was the electrodes
measured
arousal in their genitals and they were
supposed to click on a button if they
were aroused by an erotic image they
were shown
okay i've heard of the study okay you
have yeah i know the results of the
story okay
all right tell me so then you know
exactly where i'm going with this so
they showed that they asked the man what
do you like the guy said well i like you
know lesbians and
you know heterosexual sex cool show
those erotic images as well as other
images like you know monkeys banging
homosexual sex whatever
guess what he tapped the button when he
was aroused and the electrodes
signified the correlation between the
two basically when he collected it he
also got aroused so he didn't lie
homosexual man what are you turned on by
well i like homosexual sex all right
cool
show it to him show him the image clicks
the button aroused right
that's the women what are you aroused by
well surprise not surprisingly enough
all the women said hey i'm aroused by
politically correct
things sex maybe some girls kissing
whatever
right now when they show them the images
what the women clicked on and what they
were aroused by
two different things they were aroused
by the monkeys banging
the lesbian sex men walking on the beach
with no shirt on whatever
basically a lot of the things they said
they were not attracted by they were
actually
aroused by when the generals read the
electrodes read their generals
and it did not link with what they
tapped that they liked what they tapped
that they liked were politically correct
things
to women men and women kissing blah blah
so
it goes to show my point that's really
interesting there's an enormous amount
of social
but do you think you can base a claim
off of one
study like one study do you think that
you can base an
entire like premise of like but like the
premise you don't take dating advice
from women and this is actually why i
hold off on giving any advice because
that's literally the whole manosphere
just says don't take advice from women
but um what i was saying is that
like do you think that that one study is
gonna
get like that is enough to back up the
entire claim that women don't know what
they're aroused by
social pressure on women to be sexually
attracted to and or be aroused by things
that are socially
politically correct so that they don't
come off as hoes okay
so so when i tell guys don't listen to
what
women tell you when it comes to what
they're attracted to or whatever
there's a reason for it it's because
what there's a strong social incentive
for women to lie
to you about what they're actually
arousing but can i add i think that men
are i want to interrupt you again i'm
sorry let me talk after this but i think
men are
are encouraged to explore sexuality more
than women are so maybe that has
a correlation yeah right that's that's
what i was thinking
that it's probably embarrassing
i've never done this study but i would
be pretty embarrassed if i was turned on
by monkeys i don't
oh my god i'm so sorry for attracting
you go right ahead yeah there's social
stigma on a woman being uh open sexually
so they're going to lie
and uh you know cover things up and you
know minimize whatever it may be when it
comes to sexuality because they don't
want to be looked at as host
yeah can i can you show something to
them okay so
you see how you're saying this and i
told you but you see why are you adding
statistics because you don't know what
how many times have i said i'm gonna
suck someone's dick on this [ __ ] how
many times have i said i'm a [ __ ] on
this [ __ ] how many times have i said oh
yeah i've had one night stands and i
just wanted to go to a guy to [ __ ]
but it's because i don't give a [ __ ]
whether you look at me as a [ __ ] right
not i know i'm not one
type of [ __ ] so it's like that's where i
say like like does the stick says like
that
you shouldn't compare something to
someone yeah but you see like for
example
you say that right but she didn't say
that for example we say look at actions
over words actions prove a lot not just
what you're saying look there's a panel
for women here yeah you're the only one
that's come out and said that only one
so let's
let's let's like put that in a huge
population of women
yeah so right now we could say right one
in four women wonderful be honest about
their sexuality
i'll tell you this a small number it's
actually way smaller than that
way smaller it's just that one and four
so we teach guys
on a balance of probabilities what to
expect what you're saying is
the exception should make the rule no
that's not the way the world works
so i'm sorry but someone you're saying
they're gonna act a certain way and i'ma
tell them look i don't like that and
they're still gonna act that same
[ __ ] way because they think oh she's
lying
like this is what this person told me to
do like they like it when we're [ __ ]
i'm sorry but i told you exactly what i
didn't like there's no reason for me to
lie
what i'm saying is that on a see you're
you're pointing the world around you
what i'm saying is that
men need to understand that women are
going to be
very prone to lying about what they're
actually aroused by
i thought the world doesn't revolve
around okay yeah it's like well you're
telling me if some guy i told a guy
don't do this and he's gonna listen to
your dating advice
this isn't about you this is about facts
and statistics
on a whole whole scale on
based on the population because
unfortunately even though you're saying
well i'm open sexually i've admitted
this i've admitted that
most women aren't like you yeah they
want a thousand percent yeah so so if
we're going to teach men how to deal
with women should we teach them how to
deal with the exception to the rule or
the generality
huh that's interesting um
that is so interesting the study that
women like don't know what they're
attracted to
i would definitely say that that's
somewhat true
because i have noticed that like the
same girls that like talk [ __ ] about a
guy like the more
oh my gosh this sounds so bad but the
more i hear
a girl like say how she can't stand a
guy the more
i'm like ah he's got her wrapped around
his finger a little bit
so
yeah i could see that being true anyways
let me know in the comments what you
guys think is true
not true do not forget to subscribe guys
subscribe to the channel
bring that notification bell i will talk
to you guys next time